you can really see um even though Bobby
fiser gave up a queen all of his pieces
are working really well together now
after he starts to attack the Queen the
queen comes to B6 trying to gobble up
some material but at the same time it's
still kind of lost right here Bobby
fiser now decides to come in and take
this Rook on
D1 and now burn decides that he really
needs to get his King out of the way his
King really can't move um and so you
know lot of threats that Bobby Fischer
has he can come down and Checkmate um
you know once he starts to take some
pieces off the board so he knows that he
needs to really start to try to
Counterattack and really get somewhere
for his King to go here so he plays Pawn
2 H3 and from here Bobby Fischer decides
to go ahead and take this Pawn on A2
doesn't really want to have to worry
about any pawns on the queen side so now
he can pretty much Focus all his
attention on the king